DEAD RIVALRY:
Hundreds of millions
of people are ditching Android. Once upon a
time, the rivalry between Android and iPhone
was one of the biggest in the world. It was as
divisive and alienating as politics, religion,
and whether you eat the frosting in an Oreo
first. The iPhoners were seen as snobs who
worshipped Steve Jobs and were willing to pay up
any price. Meanwhile, the Androiders were seen as
the geeks who just didn’t quite understand the
elegance of the iPhone. For the longest time,
it seemed like this battle had been settled the
same way as the PC vs Mac battle. The PC was the
choice for the overwhelming majority while the
Mac was the choice for a few creative types,
coders, and of course snobs. But, it’s not
quite playing out the same way within the
smartphone space. In fact, the iPhone has
not only been gaining on Android but it
has straight up overtaken Android in terms of
popularity within the US. Things haven’t gone
that far internationally but the iPhone
is still very much gaining on Android
outside of the US as well. In fact, within just
the last 5 years, Android’s global market share
has fallen 8% from 77 down to 69. That might
not sound like a lot but keep in mind, virtually
everyone in the entire world has a smartphone.
We’re talking about 6.92 billion people. So an
8% loss in marketshare translates to over half
a billion people switching teams. Another decade
of that and Android will no longer control the
majority. And honestly, looking past the numbers,
it seems that this shift is already underway. Back
in day, it was the iPhone users that were seen as
the outsiders, the select minority of Apple
sheep. But, today, it’s usually the Android
users that are seen as the outsiders. A green text
bubble is a legitimate reason to not date someone,
facetime is a must have, and even flagship apps
like Instagram and Snapchat are very much biased
towards iPhone as they work way better on iPhone.
This is especially true for younger generations,
aka the future of the smartphone market, of whom
79% prefer iPhone. Hearing that, it seems like
the demise of Android is almost inevitable,
so what happened to the king of smartphones?
THE CASE FOR ANDROID:
To answer what happened to
the Android community, we first have to take
a look back at what gave rise to the Android
community in the first palace and for
that, we have to go all the way back to
October of 2003. This is when four friends
named Andy Rubin, Rich Miner, Nick Sears,
and Chris White would create Android but it was
nothing like what we know today. In fact, Android
wasn’t even meant for smartphones as smartphones
weren’t even a thing. Android was actually trying
to create better software for digital cameras
but they quickly figured out that this was a
rather niche industry with little money. So, out
of desperation, they would pivot to the mobile
phone industry which got off to a surprisingly
strong start. In fact, they would end up having
conversations talks with Samsung and HTC. And
these negotiations would catch the attention
of an up and coming startup named Google, you
might’ve heard of them. Google would go ahead
and buyout the company for a mere $50 million.
With Google’s backing, Android no longer had to
worry about funding but they still didn’t have a
winning product in their hands. In fact, Android
was initially being developed for blackberry like
devices with physical keyboards and no touchscreen
functionality. It wasn’t until the launch of the
iPhone that Google went back to the drawing board
and focused on a touch screen based experience.
Even then though, they wanted some fundamental
functions to be represented by physical buttons.
And that’s why all the early Androids came with
the classic 3 buttons at the bottom. This blatant
copying made Steve Jobs furious as he would vow
to destroy Android but that’s a wholenother story.
The fact was that while Android had a rocky start,
the 2010s would be a rocketship as their
marketshare exploded from some 20% to nearly 70%.
This explosion can be attributed to 3 main factors
starting with price. This one is pretty self
explanatory. Androids were in general far cheaper
than iPhones. The cheapest Androids started at
just $100 to $200 making them far more accessible
than the $600 to $700 iPhones especially in
developing countries. But, don’t let this cheap
price fool you into thinking that Androids weren’t
capable. In fact, Androids often had way better
specs than iPhones for half the price which brings
us into our second point for Android: performance.
Before Samsung started cheating on benchmarks
and got banned from Geekbench, they used to
legitimately be the king of performance and
it’s no wonder why. Just take a look at the specs
of the iPhone 6 and the Galaxy S6 for example.
The Samsung had a 40% larger battery, a nearly
2 times higher pixel density, 3 times more ram,
a 3.5 times higher resolution, over 5 times
the CPU speed, and a camera with double the
megapixels. So, for people who made their choice
based on the spec sheet and price to performance,
Android was the clear way to go. And speaking
of choices, there were simply far more choices
with Android. You could go with Samsung,
Google, HTC, OnePlus, Oppo, Xiaomi, Huawei,
and basically anyone else who wanted in on the
smartphone market. Meanwhile, from Apple’s side,
there wasn’t even phones with different screen
sizes up until the iPhone 6. You basically had
to choose between a white iPhone and a black
iPhone and that was pretty much it. Also, this
abundance of choice or lack thereof extended well
beyond the brand of the phone. With Androids, you
could take advantage of widgets, swap batteries
in a matter of seconds, and add storage like it
was nothing. And let’s not forget about how easy
it was to jailbreak them. Jailbreaking or enabling
root access to an Android phone was literally
a matter of pressing a button. With iPhones,
on the other hand, jailbreaking was a long and
tense process as you hoped and prayed that you
didn’t brick your phone. But anyway, putting my
childhood fears to the side, when you combine the
price, performance, and customizability
of Androids, it’s no wonder why Android
became so popular. But, clearly, these factors
aren’t holding up in 2023, so what happened?
THE CASE FOR IPHONE:
Looking back, I don’t think any of Android’s
winning factors have necessarily fallen out of
favor. People still want price, performance,
and control but then why is Android getting
destroyed? Well, I would argue that Android no
longer offers any of these while Apple has made
strides in all of these. Let’s start with price
for example. Everyone loves to talk about how
iPhones have become far more expensive but have
you looked at the Android market? The original
Samsung Galaxy S1 was launched for $400 in 2010
alongside the iPhone 4 which launched for $600.
So, the Samsung was a solid 33% cheaper. But
since then, the price of the Galaxy has not
only matched the price of the iPhone or even
the pro iPhone. It has literally overtaken the
pro max iPhone as the Galaxy S20 Plus started at
$1200. And it’s not just Samsung who has jacked
up prices. Android prices have exploded to match
iPhone prices across the board as everyone tries
to be seen as the premium smartphone premium.
Even the Google Pixel 7a which is supposed to
be the budget phone now starts at $500. Now of
course, you could argue that the price of the
iPhone has also skyrocketed during this time
period and that’s completely true, but there’s
one major difference. By jacking up prices, Apple
wasn’t cannabilizing their own userbase. In fact,
they were just building up the status and appeal
of their phone which is why a lot of people buy
their phones in the first place. Android on the
other hand was cannabilizing their userbase.
When an Android user sees that the new galaxy
is more expensive that the flagship iPhone,
most don’t say “Wow, Samsung has really stepped up
their quality and status.” Instead, they go “Damn,
if it’s more expensive than the iPhone,
I might as well just get the iPhone.”
This has only been exacerbated by Apple becoming
a lot friendlier when it comes to pricing.
All we hear about Apple is their flagship
costing more than ever but here’s the deal,
the flagships aren’t meant for the average person.
They're meant for the people who want the best
regardless of price and to shape the Apple brand
image. For everyone else, Apple has actually been
offering cheaper phones than ever starting at
just $430 and going up in increments of $100.
So, as Androids have become more expensive
and entry level iPhones have become cheaper,
pricing has become a non factor when choosing
between iPhone and Android especially when you
throw in carrier deals that largely favor iPhones.
But, it’s not just pricing that Android has lost
out on, they’ve also lost out on performance. A
lot of Android phones still have better batteries
and better processors and more RAM and all
of that stuff but this no longer translates
into real world performance. You see, Apple has
gotten extremely good at optimizing their software
to work in synergy with their hardware. So, even
though they still often have worse specs on paper,
they actually end up having better performance and
battery life. Take the Samsung Galaxy S23 and the
iPhone 14 Pro Max for example. On Geekbench, the
S23 Ultra comes in at 1877 and 4968 ultra while
the 14 pro max comes in at 2516 and 6351. In fact,
the top 20 scoring mobile devices all come from
Apple but honestly, this is completely irrelevant
because in 2023, performance itself is irrelevant.
And that’s not to say that people don’t
care about performance but rather that all
reputable smartphones are more than capable.
So, performance has also become a non factor
which brings us into the last hero factor for
Android which was customizability. To be blunt,
Android’s customizability has fallen off a cliff.
They’ve very much taken the Apple approach when
it comes to customizing the hardware. You can no
longer switch batteries or upgrade storage or even
plug in headphones. Even getting a charging brick
is an anomaly nowadays. These android phonemakers
think that this makes them more premium and
more like Apple but really it just makes them
less appealing. And as for the software side of
things, Android is indeed still customizable but
so is iPhone. After resisting for years, Apple
has finally caved and given users customization
options whether that’s dark mode or widgets or
different fonts or whatever else. This has not
only completely eliminated the need to jailbreak
but also the last remaining advantage of Android.
But honestly while these factors offer
a logical explanation for the downfall
of Android, I think there’s also a
more qualitative explanation at play.
WHAT REALLY HAPPENED:
As you can see, Android has inarguably lost
much of it’s distinguishing appeal over the
past decade but I think there’s more to
this trend than just objective reasoning.
The X factor that we have yet to discuss
is the rising importance of smartphones.
Back in the early 2010s, smartphones were the new
tool. It helped you reply to emails and surf the
web and chat more conveniently than ever. Most
were looking for the cheapest and most practical
way to accomplish these tasks and this set the
context for their purchasing decision. They
weren’t as concerned about small bugs or having
the perfect UI or the smartphones experience or
all of these other factors that Apple focused on.
These were seen as nice to haves or luxuries but
by no means necessities and as such, the majority
went with Android. But the role of the smartphone
within society has largely transformed over the
past 10 years. Smartphones are no longer a tool,
they are a necessity to engage with the modern
society and economy. As such, people are more
willing to invest in a nice smartphone instead
trying to get the cheapest one the market.
Moreover, people value the experience part of it
more than ever. They enjoy how seamless iMessage,
and Facetime, and now even phone calls are on
the iPhone. They appreciate that all of their
favorite apps are natively built for the
iPhone even if they don’t know that’s why
iPhone apps feel better. They love the synergy
between their smartphone and all of their other
Apple tech gadgets. And most importantly, they
value fitting in with their friends and family.
Combine this with the fact that Androids are now
just as expensive, lost their performance lead,
and come along with the same shortfalls as Apple,
and there’s really no reason not to switch to
iPhone. And looking forward, this trend will
only amplify as younger generations value these
characteristics more than ever. And that’s why
everyone is ditching Android. I would also argue
that the modern tech economy is destroying the
middle class. Check out this video to learn more.